I was suffering from post-traumatic
stress disorder depression and grief I
was going downhill fast
ketamine's use as a transformer of mood
is only discovered in the late 90s and
people were very incredulous it's an
anesthetic how could it have anything to
do with mood what is actually happening
in the brain when a person takes this
drug I'm always a little nervous before
the injection because I know I have no
control over what my mind is going to
think about the trauma that I'm dealing
with basically unthinkable but I've lost
both of my children to suicide my
youngest son Dylan knew that his life
mattered that he mattered that he had a
voice and unfortunately his impulsive
nature caused him to go in and shoot
himself and end his life when I found
him I screamed uncontrollably what I saw
nobody should see I ran out of the house
hidden trapped back in to make sure he
wasn't wasn't still alive even though
it's physically impossible basically
like what I looked up I hired a grief
counselor immediately I hired the best
post traumatic stress disorder counselor
I could find and I did pull myself out
of it I did reengage and I had an older
son who's still with his mum and I
worried about him because he didn't go
to counseling and he held things in he
didn't share but he kept saying he was
fine and we were about to go to the
edmonton oilers playoff game with my dad
and my sister because I really believed
in trying to unite the family start
having us live our lives again that was
my obligation to others friends and
family and my son my son was clearly
depressed but he denied it
l'Damian before he was supposed to go
back to see his mother he called me on a
bike ride to tell me that he loved me
and I knew something was wrong when he
asked me how long it was gonna be it
reminded me of my other son when he
asked me the same question when I got
home a year ago about today I found my
other son dead of a gunshot wound
[Music]
needless to say I fell apart
brought in spiritual leaders I brought
in other counselors any ideas that
people had that could help me get a grip
of my life cuz for the first 4 months I
didn't care if I was alive I didn't care
if I died I didn't think it mattered I
had no hope I had no purpose
it was empty without my kids I first
went to some grief recovery centers I
went to a brain scanning clinic I signed
up with an EMDR specialist I was
severely depressed trying to get out of
it and I wanted to try to make some
progress on my own before I came to do
the ketamine and I wanted to get through
Christmas so having have lost one son
and knowing the worst date is Christmas
not the birth date not the anniversary
dated that Christmas is the worst date
if you've lost a child I knew they had
that coming and I didn't want to be
doing this or have just done it and then
get whacked again so I knew to get
through Christmas if I could get through
Christmas early January I'm flying back
into LA and I'm gonna come and spend two
weeks and do this treatment and I got
through Christmas and I made it here
[Music]
it's known as Special K a psychedelic
drug popular in dance clubs but doctors
say this same drug ketamine approved as
animal tranquilizer and anaesthetic can
also be a lifesaver when used to treat
severe depression when nothing else
works one small study found ketamine
decreased suicidal thoughts almost
immediately in 50% of patients most
antidepressants take weeks
tom was pretty troubled when he came to
us he was not dealing it all well Tom
really was blaming himself a lot for
that and we're suffering a great deal of
guilt and remorse pretty unsure about
whether he wanted to continue living he
had a very rough and contentious first
infusion by the day after his second
infusion he was really just singing the
praises of the treatment ketamine was
found to be profoundly effective
anesthetic given us a lump or bolus it
was only when people began to give it in
a very gradual way and its sub
anesthetic doses that we realized what
an amazing mood elevator and reversal
suicidality it is starts a chain
reaction it actually caused new growth
in connections in the brain and in
receptor density among those connections
the patient who has an infusion
experiences a disassociative state does
not have true hallucinations you may see
things that aren't there but he knows
that they're not there this association
can be very mild like when you're
waiting to pay at the grocery store
you're thinking about what you're going
to do tonight your mind and body are
sort of separate a lot of patients tell
us that they're able to do really
important internal work while they're
having an infusion it can be really
therapeutic for them to have a really
objective perspective on their life and
this dissociation that dr. Mendel is
talking about of course it's very
important we're big advocates of talk
therapy and for them to work through
some of these things with a professional
it's a treatment it's not a cure
it will not stand alone for me I'm
always a little nervous before the
injection because I know I have no
control over what my mind is going to
think about and it can go from very
pleasant the very scary I know at the
end I'm going to feel better I'm going
to say it's an out-of-body experience
I'm present watching myself but it's not
in a dimension that I can explain they
actually let me know that I matter that
I am good enough they gave me tools to
discuss with my conventional
psychologist
[Music]
I had moments of emotional pain from my
loss that I understood why somebody
would want to take their life and for
whatever reason something changed in me
that made me go from I don't care if I
live to I don't want to die and now
because of these treatments I can now go
and share my story and let people know
that life is worth living that as bad as
it gets us as painful it gets we do have
a choice and we have freedom to make
that choice but I can go out and help
other people possibly and whether I'm
successful or not doesn't matter I'm at
least gonna try to do that I'm gonna try
to give back with this clinics giving me
my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]